support the david pakman show and pick
yourself up a Janus SmartWatch designed
by Chronos blade I love mine it can do
anything my phone can do you can take
photos with the dual camera a
videoconference download any Android app
use it as a fitness tool it can make
calls like a phone it has GPS it has one
of the biggest screens out there 1.6
inches
check it out using the link right
underneath this video okay it's time for
a fight my favorite story Segway hey
this is kind of weird
Trump's White House advisor Kellyanne
Conway who just recently you might know
or have heard she recently ignored a
request to appear before lawmakers to
answer serious questions about her Hatch
Act violations Kelly Ann Conway asked a
reporter who happens to be Jewish
ethnically what his ethnicity is when he
asked a question of Kelly Ann Conway
about Donald Trump's recent comments
that some Congress women who were ethnic
minorities should return to their quote
original countries the reporter is
Andrew Feinberg who again but by his
name my belief is that he is ethnically
Ashkenazi Jewish he was at he asked if
the president was not telling those for
Congress women to return to their
supposed countries of origin to which
countries was he referring it's a good
question in Kellyanne Conway apparently
didn't like it will pick it up there
speaking I just follow it following up
can we following up on the previous
question if the president was not
telling these these for congresswoman to
return to their supposed countries of
origin to which countries was he
referring
why is that relevant to this conference
my F my Kelly my own ethnicity is not
relevant to the question I'm asking it
I'm asking you no no I'm asking you to
which which so are you are you saying
that the president was telling the
Palestinian American to go back to I
just love the pause when she asks what's
your ethnicity the reporter Andrew
Feinberg in stunned into silence
literally now immediately lots of people
online started saying is this
anti-semitic because Kellyanne Conway
presumably knowing that Andrew
Feinberg's ethnicity not race notably
his ethnicity is Ashkenazi Jewish to the
extent that we differentiate between
race and ethnicity and it's all sort of
a question at this point um I actually
don't think she's that clever to be
totally honest I don't think that this
was anti-semitic I think it was
mind-numbingly stupid now I'm certainly
open to the idea that she did this to an
ethnically Jewish reporter I just have
not seen any evidence of that so far she
wasn't uh you know checking to see why
he's not wearing his yellow star that
he's supposed to be wearing or something
like that I think she's just a [ __ ] and
this is potentially even a planned
distraction because if I were trying to
prove how not racist I was and how not
racist my boss was I don't know that I'd
start asking reporters to list their
ethnicities when they ask questions now
I hate to do this but I feel almost like
I have to when I saw Kelly Anne say
what's your ethnicity my mind went to
one cultural critic Dave Rubin did
stand-up comedy and asked audience
members their sexual orientation
remember when this went down hot gay
comics live for television by show of
hands how many of you have televisions
have you have a pretty good okay and how
many of you have the here network
oK we've got some work to do but we're
very good so do we have all gay people
is everyone here
gay you're gay very good very good do we
have some a lot of discussion like to
tell me you just come out right then
yeah just always ask anyone you're
talking to ethnicity and sexual
orientation please just so that you know
and you know how to contextualize the
conversation so anyway this is shaping
up to be a very very xenophobic and
racist election cycle and I hope
everybody's buckled in for it is this I
mean maybe I'm wrong should this be a
strategy I adopt when I do interviews on
the show where I ask for ethnicity
joining me today is Richard wolf
economist my former professor at the
University of Massachusetts professor
wolf before we get started what is your
ethnicity just so we understand Oh
Ashkenazi Jewish got it all right well
let's continue now with the interview
now Kellyanne Conway later tweeted about
this saying quote this was meant with no
disrespect we are all from somewhere
else
quote originally I asked the question to
answer the question and volunteered my
own ethnicity it's Hallion and Irish
like many I am proud of my ethnicity
love of the United States of America and
grateful to God to be an American this
is such a dumb explanation right that we
are all quote originally from somewhere
else only confirms how outrageously
stupid Donald Trump's comment was
because Donald Trump's family is from
somewhere not in the United States much
more recently than Alexandria Cascio
Cortes is you're not really doing
yourself any favors Kellyanne with this
explanation that listen we're all from
somewhere so I was just asking that
question to make that point well that
makes Trump look even worse as a result
we are in an age of idiocracy III I
don't know how to interpret this is this
as some have suggested anti-semitism by
Kellyanne Conway because the reporter
was Jewish I don't think so but I'm open
to having my mind changed is this a
deliberate attempt to distract from the
things that Donald Trump said with an
even dumber comment I don't know I sort
of have a hard time believing that is
this Kellyanne Conway just trying to
make a point but failing and
embarrassing herself maybe that's the
most likely circumstance I don't know
the answer but I do want to hear from
you what do you think this is all about
I do have a post about this up on
Instagram make sure you follow me there
at David Pakman and while you're there
follow the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show for a
bunch of great behind-the-scenes
pictures and videos and lots of really
great stuff we'll take a quick break
many more stories to discuss with you
today hope you'll stay with us